well she's trying to address voters
after a tumultuous couple of days in
British politics trying to sort of
reconnect established control we saw
that immediately after winning this
confidence vote the Prime Minister
wished to talk I think let's talk to her
let's see directly was yesterday this
evening the government has won the
confidence of Parliament this now gives
us all the opportunity to focus on
finding a way forward on brexit I
understand that two people getting on
with their lives away from Westminster
the events of the past 24 hours will
have been unsettling overwhelmingly the
British people want us to get on with
delivering brexit and also addressed the
other important issues they care about
but the deal which I have worked to
agree with the European Union was
rejected by MPs and by a large margin
I believe it is my duty to deliver on
the British people's instruction to
leave the European Union and I intend to
do so so now MPs have made clear what
they don't want we must all work
constructively together to set out what
Parliament does want that's why I'm
inviting MPs from all parties to come
together to find a way forward one that
both delivers on the referendum and can
command the support of Parliament this
is now the time to put self-interest
aside I have just held constructive
meetings with the leader of the Liberal
Democrats and the Westminster leaders of
the SNP and plied kumari from tomorrow
meetings will be taking place between
senior government representatives
including myself and groups of MPs who
represent the widest possible range of
views from accross Parliament including
our confidence and supply partners the
Democratic Unionist Party I am
disappointed that the leader of the
Labour Party has not so far chosen to
take part but our door remains Oh
it will not be an easy task but MPs know
they have a duty to act in the national
interest reach a consensus and get this
done in a historic vote in 2016 the
country decided to leave the EU in 2017
80 percent of people voted for parties
that stood on manifestos promising to
respect that result now over two and a
half years later it's time for us to
come together put the national interest
first and deliver on the referendum
so treason we're heading back into
number 10 Downing Street accepting their
that it had been an unsettling period
and that her deal had been roundly
rejected by a large margin time she said
to work constructively together she has
met some opposition leaders this evening
but Fryzel not Jeremy Corbyn although
she reiterated there that her door is
always open well I mean I think it has
to be said there was nothing new there
from the Prime Minister an attempt to
reassure those at home who felt that
maybe brexit slipping away that she's
still in charge of the process and there
was an update was there not on the
meeting she has had with the leaders of
applied of the West Minister leaders of
the SNP